Maxim Yasser and Nazi are asking did you
feel like perhaps Wesley underestimated
his position at the end was he perhaps
better did you feel any pressure coming
from him
um yeah I must admit I was not
completely happy with the way I handled
my opening stage
so um
I played this F4 bit out of necessity
because I don't want to allow e596.
Let's uh talk about the position in fact
you started off with the London how did
I mean this must be a trend coming from
the world championship match is that the
case uh technically I even played it one
day before before
yeah exactly yeah so but yeah of course
like
we know those ideas but I mean if we
should credit anyone for you know making
the random Trend it's Magnus obviously
let's talk about it so Knight to H5
Bishop G5 yeah this came as a surprise
of course
like there's this position in the slab
but I play Knight D2 so I'm on Tempo up
which means after Bishop G5 there's no
more Queen B6
because of 95 I assume 95 here for
instance
yes and now you have some problems with
the light on H5 but so I knew that I
mean Bishop G5 should be the critical
try but after F6 g6i
couldn't really figure it out
did you feel like he still knew what
he's doing absolutely probably and uh
sadly this was one option I
didn't really reconsider before the game
um Bishop Ito was not too happy with my
main point was if Knight G7 then I take
on C5 and adjust to stop it for a second
we just saw Anish and alireza finished
their respective game as well that
finished in a draw Let's uh continue
Maxim yes
take on D4 Knight takes D4 Knight to G7
yeah and here's where I didn't really
enjoy
too much my position because I feel like
for instance if I Castle which should be
the normal way of handling this an id4 I
take with let's say sipon I assumed a
knight F5 and
maybe this is not the end of the world
but I felt like if anyone's gonna be
better it's black now this position and
it strikes me a bit as oh it's not a
very conventional position right
as a beginner if you look at it white
has all almost all the pieces developed
Black's Knight is on G7 you moved E6 F6
my pieces are developed but at the same
time I'm slow now in you know getting
them two better squares whereas for
Western it's very easy like in to move
this this gasoline is not can always
drop into F5
which is why I lost time you know to
take to play E4 and then I snap him from
going Knight to F5 and then to play F4
which I felt was not ideal but
um but at the same time again if I
Castle
E5 I don't really know what to do
maybe here four but
I don't think this was working to be
honest
but maybe you can start with castle and
then play the player for because for
Queen B6 check here now later play E5 I
mean
yeah Castle identify because of yeah
yeah it's so anyway I went F4 I thought
maybe sometimes I guess or queen size
but after Queen B6 he has a problem is
Queen C2
through this move which
I
I mean if Bishop A6 C4 was kind of
okay with that because I want Queen C3
next
but after Castle I just couldn't figure
out what I should do
could I force yeah right no I I actually
considered it here
and it's actually move yeah yeah
but I thought castle and
like oh Queen C6 now
come on oh yeah yeah yeah no no so then
Bishop D7
but yeah
I don't know it felt artificial
and
I was also considering for but even
after Queen bitu
this I was not completely happy with
maybe it's
just winning for white but
that's a wild life yeah but also Euro
Cup what you do probably lose a night
yeah I have to process yeah I mean
but of course you can also go Bishop D7
and I'm not sure what I achieved so I
just thought Queen B3 is a safe option
because now if Queen history my point is
C4
this is quite nice Queen F4 I think I oh
no of course not
he's in fact but if one takes Queen
takes so and after Queen G5 no CD and
some Knight F3 and one turns out I'm
winning so Queen is in trouble yeah so
this was some kind of Cheap Trick I had
but after Castle it meant that I had to
take
and yeah maybe I shouldn't Castle maybe
castling was too too quick but the thing
that I missed is after rookie one
uh it takes
and Knight H5 now yeah and I'm stuck you
cannot go G3 because of G5 yes you lose
the bishop you have to give up the
bishop but that's problematic right so
you know I realized the same time I took
an A6 and played E5 and maybe I'm worse
but
but I don't know I was not too
enough is not that I exchange uh
energy do you feel like he was happy
with the draw as well yeah I thought
there were two options I'm not sure that
twister was up he was a draw he felt
like he was better I think
uh this was one option I thought but
then I just got Knight F3 and C5 I
let's say
I mean I I shouldn't be too much worse
it doesn't look like much
more and another which I saw yesterday
mentioning but I thought it was risky
more than anything with this
no I want like B3 song f8
and
we thought okay like this with maybe too
much so let's say
A3 C4 but
I mean as soon as I have G4 you know
this Knight on G7 is very
it takes a while to get it back in the
game right yeah so I thought I should be
more or less fine even if I lose a bit
of plant some I get contemporary on F5
and yeah yeah no it definitely looks
risky for him as well yeah so I thought
I was not too happy with this
um I thought this was a nice try also
but it turns out that I'm fine
engage one and if 93 I can play hook F3
if not I'm probably worse after Knight
G4 but oh that makes a lot of sense yeah
now in ig4 you can just give up the pawn
back
this should be good
Rook do you want have some pressure on
the E5 yes exactly this one looks uh so
maybe even better for you at this point
yeah no it finished I mean I wouldn't
say better okay I see you know the eval
but I wouldn't have said better
um yes the game finished maybe a bit
untimely but like there were some some
moments how would you assess the start
of the tournament you haven't played
well you actually play some uh leagues
uh in precise
it was important because I didn't have
any any other classical game before that
in 2023 and my last tournament you know
was such stronger position was uh back
in sinful cup so you know it's good to
get back some
how do you feel about your form right
now coming along nicely yeah it's it's
quite all right
um obviously today was not very
satisfying yesterday was better but you
know those of course it will take you
know one one we know one last two
to make a break they're definitely part
of the game Maxine thank you very much
for joining us we'll see you in the rest
of the rounds thank you question thank
you Christian thank you mvl actually a
quick question if I might ask to mvl
first of all greetings from St Louis mvl
uh you're the defending Champion but
against Wesley so you have a remarkable
plus score how did you do it and coming
into today's game did you feel like you
were going to continue proceedings
Yasser is saying that against Wesley saw
they checked the graphics before the
game started you have an amazing score I
think six victories and only one loss
did you feel like that's playing a part
in your Encounters in general
putting more pressure on him maybe but
in general it's mostly because I haven't
taken as many ways maybe as other
players against Wesley because he's very
good at punishing those
and yeah in a few games I got some nice
advantage that I managed to to a lot and
of course I I wanted to to get something
and maybe I took a bit more risk than
usual to you know because I had charging
picture but novelty about the Berlin and
he said one D4 yeah so you know
um it didn't
um Gods where I planned but
you know of course uh but I want every
game I have with white generally you
know I
I wouldn't say always but more or less
always want to to get a game and to get
something going so basically the
takeaway from this discussion is that
you should always trust chat GPD
or maybe I shouldn't yes sir do you even
know what chat GPD is
no
I'll show him after the stream
[Laughter]
um thank you thank you for the answer
three draws uh in this the second